lorsqu'on dit à l'heure actuelle que par
exemple on a la capacité de pouvoir
travailler à distance
ça veut dire également que l'on peut
renchérir la vie locale par exemple
c'est à dire que l'on se trouve
exactement dans dance qui est ce que
propose par exemple
edgar morin dans la voix dans la voix
vous avez à la fois le côté je dirais
mondiale qui est en train de se mettre
en place et d'autre part vous avez
également tout ce qui doit se faire au
niveau du local et le télétravail permet
cela lorsqu'on dit que par aig par
exemple le fait de pouvoir t'aider
travailler à partir de chez soi ou près
de chez soi ça veut dire que l'on remet
de l'activité par exemple dans des zones
rurales
il ya des tas d'exemples maintenant en
france où ça a été le cas est ce que
ceci va à l'encontre de l'universalité
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure nous ça
va de pair on est sur une sur le des
deux tranches d'une pièce de monnaie ou
il y à aussi bien la vie du local qui
est renchéri que la vie je dirai au
niveau du global qui est également
possible et cela c'est nouveau par
rapport à ce que ça existait avant
est-ce que ça il faut se le privé la
réponse elle est positivement pour moi
quelque chose de constructif et plaids
et sans doute d'avenir pour pouvoir
répondre justement aux difficultés qui
s'amène et que nous allons avoir dans
les années qui viennent
c'est évident refaire commun qu'est ce
que ça veut dire faire comme un repère
commun est ce qu'on fait comme un
obligatoirement dans des entreprises où
aujourd'hui il y a dix mille 15 mille
cinquante mille salariés ou est-ce qu'on
fait commun avec je dirais son
environnement qui est proche
toutes les études sociologiques montrent
que finalement on connaît lorsqu'on est
dans le travail on connaît au maximum à
peu près 200 personnes le commun donc
ses 200 personnes aujourd'hui avec le
télétravail vous pouvez très bien dans
une zone géographique donnée à une
petite ville de 2000 ou 3000 habitants
reconnaître également les autres les
travailleurs du coin pour pouvoir
travailler dans un espace de coworking
est à refaire commun
donc le travail n'est pas une
suppression du commun en tant que tel
[Musique]